there's roughly 74 million fathers in
America today and every single one of
them at some point is going to
experience these three phases you go
through with your kids that applies also
to business and in life so before I get
into it if this gives you any value give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel what are the three phases first
phase it's a beautiful face it's when
your kids totally idolize their dads oh
my God my dad is so awesome we play
catch together we go out and have a good
time together my dad is amazing and then
all of a sudden kid gets a little bit
older then Dad does things wrong dad
doesn't have a clue what he's doing then
you go through the demonized phase my
dad is horrible he's so controlling he
doesn't care about me he doesn't do this
he doesn't do that and you may go
through a phase of a couple years maybe
five ten years sometimes it lasts over
10 years well you just totally demonize
your debt your dad can't do anything
right and then one day you wake up
typically it happens when you become a
father and then you start humanizing
your father and you say man
he's kind of right you know things
he said that was kind of right this was
right all this other stuff that takes
place so again you may be watching this
as a kid saying I'm in the face right
now but you don't understand my dad is
different he's horrible he's this he's
dead fine no problem by the way this is
not a fatherless home statistic I'm
giving you set those fathers aside that
are not there they're absent they're not
around you can say whatever you want
there I'm not talking about that I'm
talking about somebody that is active is
there is tough on you challenges you
kicks your butt pushes you all this
stuff where you have many opportunities
to have a demonizing type of an energy
towards your father let's look at a
couple different things my feedback on
both okay on on both meaning the person
that's like that's not fair versus the
person that's kicking their butt and
challenging them right I've been both
places in my career as a father as a
businessman as a CEO anybody in your
life that is going to get into the face
of Heaven to challenge you Mentor you
expect more from you there are millions
of opportunity to dislike this person
because you're going to be like when is
it ever going to be good enough for you
I let you down I didn't get this
deadline I didn't do this you're
automatically gonna resent that person a
little bit if you're able to have wisdom
and look at it and realize maybe you
didn't keep your end of the bargain
maybe you said you were gonna do
something you didn't do it maybe you're
the one that is frustrated with yourself
but you're taking it out on the easy
target which is your dad or your boss or
your CEO or your entrepreneur whoever
you're working with you're like it's all
his fault but in reality when you buy
yourself 10 years later you say
it's kind of my fault I had a guy I was
working with love this guy great guy but
he left on bad terms because I
challenged him I thought this guy was
going to be like Rockstar 10 years later
he gives me a phone call he gives me he
texts me first and say can we get on a
call I'm like why is this guy calling me
this guy didn't say a lot of good things
about me when he left he demonized
everything I was doing well we had lost
contact so I didn't know what he was up
to he says uh you got any time to get on
the call so sure let's get on a call to
you we got on a call I said what's up I
said am I not the person that you hated
and I did this and I did that and I did
this he says Pat I was 24 years old I
have no clue what the hell I was doing I
said okay cool how you doing so I wanted
to call you because it's very emotional
for me I've been wanting to call you for
the last six months I've had a hard time
giving you a call so what's that he says
I am officially the bank president for
XYZ bank and this was in San Diego it's
a UniBank president he says yes really
yeah how good are you doing very good I
said that's amazing I always knew you
had it in you to do something big and he
is quiet now he's not saying anything he
said what's up why are you quiet he says
Pat everything you taught me for that
year and a half that I work with you on
the way you challenge me you push me you
did this you did that you did this I
applied all of those things to what I'm
doing right now and I eventually became
a president and I now have people that
resent me but everybody that resents me
I go back and I think about the time
that I resented you for a couple years
and I just want to say sorry and I want
to say thank you it's the weirdest phone
call but I love the phone I get a lot of
those calls nowadays because I'm in a
tough position I'm always you know for
the most part I've been a person that's
challenging but this guy had to go
through his phase of idolizing oh my God
it's the best working with Patrick
demonizing man he's so tough on you all
he cares about is this and then humanize
damn I kind of have to do the same thing
he's going to develop the next you know
get to the next level as well so you got
those three faces but there's three
other things that you got to be thinking
about if you are the father if you are
the boss because you can't say oh it's
my son oh it's all on them no part of it
is on us as well so what is it on the
father what is it on the seal what is it
on the leader three things first phase
is body face you have to win their trust
you have to win their love they have to
know you care about them with your kid
your kid has to know I love you last
night Dylan and I are practicing this
scripture for him he keeps getting the
one word but on what is unseen
scripture Corinthians we're going back
and forth for 30 minutes eventually he
starts oh my god dad you're making I
said buddy one more time one more time
we did this for 30 minutes until boom
you got it right and he comes in and I
say hey who loves you he says you love
me so of course I love you but I want
you to crush it tomorrow because I know
what you're trying to do with your
scores first thing in the morning I'm
taking them it's like hey tell me the
description Bam Bam Bam three times you
get it back to back to back to back
right I'm in a tough position but he has
to know I love him number one is Buddy
number two is mentoring I would do this
if I were you I would do that if I were
you try reading this try doing that do
it this way do it that way how about
this how about that look at this read
this article look at this video look how
he's doing it do you see how she did it
try that it's mentoring so body
mentoring try this way and then the last
one which creates friction is challenge
and the challenge is you said you were
gonna do this why don't you do it that's
friction with your son oh my God he's
always on top and looks leave me alone
can you give me a freaking cut me some
slack hey I thought you said you guys
this month you guys weren't gonna do
this number what happened here so you
challenged I think you guys can do XYZ
well you guys putting the right effort
you guys giving your best are you
staying focused I notice a lot of times
you're watching Netflix while you're
working why are you watching shows at
work hours why are you always having a
movie playing in the background and
you're looking you're working like this
you think you can stay focused like that
oh my God if it's like I can't do
nothing at work but your boss may be
right but your leader may be right but
you can still say it and then let them
know I believe you can be x y z if you
do a b c but if you as a leader or a
father forget to inject the belief and
love in the person that you're leading
and you're driving they think that maybe
you don't love them anymore and maybe
you don't believe in them anymore
sometimes all the leader has to do is to
remind the person how much they believe
in them for the individual to say I'm
willing to receive the mentoring and
being challenged because I know for a
fact this guy loves me and cares about
me something I had to learn in my 20s
and it's not something you're ever going
to perfect that's something that's a
constant reminder to us fathers and to
us leaders to know this is going to be
happening you're never going to perfect
this you got to constantly be aware of
this if you want to have stronger
relationship with your kids and the
people that you're leading so if you got
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel I got
another video for you to watch I did a
few months ago titled the fatherless
crisis in America if you've never seen
this before click here to watch it take
care everybody
foreign
[Music]